[Music]
black letter was really an attempt to
pay more attention to the figure ground
the white spaces and the black spaces
that the letter forms made and they
wanted to have them equal as often as
possible black letter was also an
attempt to make hand drawing the letter
forms much easier and simpler because
there are less curves most of The
Strokes are straight I'll start with the
a the pen is held instead of a 23° angle
it's more like
35 come
down strictly 35° this is the
tail and we come over here and we want
to make sure that the space between The
Strokes equals the thickness of the
stroke then with the tip of the pen we
draw
that